Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls. Ladies
and germs. This is, I forgot there was a camera.
This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss Show. We have, yet again,
"The Random Show." Yes. Kev, Kev Rosero. Kevin
Rose.
Kevin Rose: Thank you for having me, Tim.
It's good to be here.
Tim Ferriss: It's good to be here in your
home.
Kevin Rose: We're in a home.
Tim Ferriss: We have our matching mini scooters.
Kevin Rose: We do.
Tim Ferriss: We also have a miniature kitchen
set behind us. We were making pinto beans
and homestyle ice cream. You may or may not
be able to see that.
Kevin Rose: Their favorite topping for pinto
beans and —
Tim Ferriss: And by them, he means his progeny.
Kevin Rose: I have a couple little ones that
hopefully will not be making an appearance
and have gone to bed, but we shall see. We
already had a break —
Tim Ferriss: We already had a princess on
the run. A little jail break. Who came flying
through? So Kevin, before recording, actually
while recording, you said this is the important
juice.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: But that was off mic, so I relayed
it into the mic. What is this important juice
that we have before us?
Kevin Rose: So, I mean, we've been doing these
shows for a very long time.
Tim Ferriss: Super long.
Kevin Rose: We've always, well, not always.
We've highlighted some of our favorite drinks
over the years and one of the things that
I — comes into my possession about once
a year is a limited edition run.
Tim Ferriss: You know it's expensive when
it's in a passive sentence form. Comes into
my possession.
Kevin Rose: That's right. It sounds very fancy.
It's just a beer, people. So one of the things
that I like to do, and we've talked about
this before at some point, but unlike wine,
the cool thing about beer is you can buy the
best beer in the world, the number one ranked
beer, and it's going to cost you a hundred
dollars.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: That's not the case with wine,
obviously.
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: So, in terms of different styles
of beer, obviously it's typically not IPAs
that win the number one slot on that, it's
some of the heavier stuff. But on the IPA
front, the second highest ranked IPA by Beer
Advocate, and I would argue the harder to
find version of the IPAs. Because the number-one
ranked IPA is called Heady Topper, and it
is in production year round.
This particular beer by Russian River Brewing
is called Pliny the Younger. Now you may have
heard Pliny the Elder, which is, you typically
find at Whole Foods and things like that.
The Younger is a limited edition run that
they do once a year and just, you used to
have to go to Russian River Brewing to actually
consume it. And just recently, probably, let's
say three or four years ago, they started
putting it in bottles. So this is it in bottle
form. I would argue that this is probably
the most sought-after IPA in the world. It
is $75 a bottle, so it's not cheap. It is
a 16-ounce bottle, though, so per ounce. Nope,
it's a, it's one pint. Yeah, one pint. So
it is, it's expensive juice, but it is quite
good. And I wanted to share it with you.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Kevin Rose: And I also wanted to tell people
out there how to find the rarest beers in
the world.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Kevin Rose: I may have mentioned this at one
crazy, long-ago Random Show, but there is
a place that I go to called MyBeerCollectibles.com.
This isn't an ad. I have nothing to do with
them. Every time I just mention any URL, you're
in the same boat!
Kevin Rose: Checkout code Kev2023.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. Exactly. Make sure you
get my 20 percent. But one of the things that,
this is what I'm probably going to get them
arrested, but one of the things that is very
difficult to do is to sell alcohol online.
And so on the beer front, if you say, and
this is true, if you were to drink this bottle,
you can sell the bottle by itself for let's
just say $5 or whatever it may be, because
the bottle is just collectible in its own
right. And so what they claim is that everything
you're buying is a collectible, and so you're
not actually buying the beer.
And so it's a peer-to-peer marketplace. And
so they have people that go and buy that.
I've been using them for several years now.
Tim Ferriss: They're going to have the best
month of sales before they get shut down.
It's going to be really a blaze of glory.
Kevin Rose: They've been okay. They've been
okay. And I always find really good sellers
on there. And you see on the side of this,
it says, "Not packaged for resale." So you
have to know somebody to get this. And yeah,
I love a good IPA. And I would say this is
up there. This is pretty good stuff.
TIm Ferriss: You know the wine world. You
know probably something about the beer world.
You also know the high-end — I'm not even
going to call them watches, God forbid — timepiece
world —
Kevin Rose: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: — very well. How much of the
fame that comes from being sought after is
derived from the quality of the product versus
the scarcity versus the positioning, if there
is such a thing? Marketing, other factors.
I've become really interested in this question,
and there's actually a spectacular episode,
I haven't listened to it yet, on LVMH and
the building of that from its very meager
beginnings to its insane current state. And
there's a book called How Luxury Lost Its
Luster, so a lot of alliteration, which I
read a long time ago. I do find the study
of sort of scarcity and high-end products
very interesting.
Kevin Rose: Have you read the book The Luxury
Strategy?
Tim Ferriss: The Luxury of Strategy?
Kevin Rose: No. The Luxury Strategy.
Tim Ferriss: The Luxury Strategy. I was like,
The Luxury of Strategy? It seems like a necessity.
No, I haven't.
Kevin Rose: It's actually another really good
one. It talks about just brand positioning
and just how to set yourself up as a really
sought-after, premier brand. Yeah, premier
brand. And some of the mistakes that brands
make where they go down market and they become
a commoditized kind of Ross Dress for Less.
It's part of the reason why the fashion industry
goes and destroys so many clothes. It's not
because they have leftover clothes. They could
go and sell them. It's what happened to Guess
Jeans, or any of these other brands where
they said, "Hey, we have this extra inventory.
Let's discount it. Let's do outlet stores.
Let's do these discounting stores," and it
ruins them.
Tim Ferriss: Then they get anchored in the
mid-market. Tthere's so many different ways
to differentiate. As one example, we're in
L.A. right now, and I had never been to Erewhon.
So for people who don't know, Erewhon is a
very famous, very expensive —
Kevin Rose: It's not expensive.
Tim Ferriss: Let me paint a picture. I went
in and I went to their hot meal cafeteria
line, and I got a couple of boxes. I mean,
it's two meals, maybe two and a half meals
for me. And I was like, oh, I got a kombucha
too, and maybe a water. And I think that was
about it. There wasn't much more to it. And
it was $147. I wanted to go there just for
the spectacle, because —
Kevin Rose: I mean, there's a dating scene
there as well.
Tim Ferriss: There's this dating scene, it's
— yeah. The point I was going to make is
I was having a conversation with someone and
I told them this story and they said, "Wow,
that's insane. I imagine if you took the same
inventory, you could sell it for 20 percent
less and do really well." And I said, "You
could, but if Erewhon lowered their prices,
they would be dead, I think." Because part
of the allure, part of the story, part of
the word of mouth is how expensive it is.
I mean, look, they have other stuff that is,
I'm sure, of incredibly high quality. And
I respect that also. But it has become, the
reason I hear about Erewhon in a place like
Austin or other places in the country is highly
exclusive, very expensive. And I'm not saying
that as a knock.
Kevin Rose: Well, just talking about grocery
stores, even though this isn't that most that
interesting of a topic —
Tim Ferriss: But this maps to a bunch of other
things.
Kevin Rose: Oh, for sure. Yeah. But I think
when you see Whole Foods get bought by Amazon
and it becomes this kind of mass scaled enterprise,
although it was, you could argue beforehand,
when you go in there, it's not the level of
quality it was a decade ago. It's just not,
it's been degraded. And this is now that next
new level.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And I would say that when you
go into Erewhon, it doesn't feel bougie though.
It doesn't feel like crazy, just luxury for
luxury's sake.
Tim Ferriss: What you mean by bougie? Because
that word gets, I've heard bougie said more
times than I can count since I got to L.A.
about a week ago.
Kevin Rose: I think it's just kind of like
the one thing, I've only been in L.A. a few
months, and the one thing that I love about
it actually is that it's a choose your own
adventure. So you can go as crazy high-end
as you want to, whatever you want to, however
you define that.
Or you can find an awesome little dive bar
with a great cocktail. And so I actually like
that. And for me, I tend to float somewhere
in the middle. Don't get me wrong, I like
a nice, awesome steak in a great killer steakhouse,
which they have a lot of those out here. But
at the same time, it's like it's different
than Portland. Like Portland, we didn't have
the high end. We had a lot of the middle.
So it's like, Erewhon is very small. It's
a very small grocery store.
Tim Ferriss: It's super small. I was actually
expecting it to be much larger.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So I'd go there, and I've been
there since. And it is high quality. The food
is high quality. I think the name is also,
if I'm getting this right, an anagram of "nowhere"
for people who may be wondering about the
name.
Kevin Rose: Interesting.
Tim Ferriss: The experience that I had actually
yesterday brought a lot of this to top of
mind for me. And my experience yesterday was
going to this place called The Magic Castle
for the second time.
Kevin Rose: Nice. You went.
Tim Ferriss: I did. And for those who don't
know about The Magic Castle, I'm not going
to do it justice, but it is the mecca of magic
in the sense that people from all over the
world, the kids who become obsessed with magic,
sleight of hand, illusion, et cetera, the
one place, if they've heard of it, that everyone
wants to go is The Magic Castle. And anyone
who's anyone, more or less, in that world
blows through the doors probably once a year.
Kevin Rose: Did you dress up?
Tim Ferriss: You have to dress up.
Kevin Rose: You have to wear a tie, right?
Tim Ferriss: This is where I was going. You
have to wear a suit and tie, not just tie,
suit and tie.
I did not come here with a suit and tie, nor
did I come here with dress shoes. So a friend
of mine who was visiting, who also didn't
have any of the fancy clothes because the
opportunity to go came up very last minute.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Men's Warehouse, we went to Hollywood
Suits on Hollywood Boulevard.
Kevin Rose: You rented?
Tim Ferriss: We, no, we couldn't rent. So
we bought suits. But here's the thing. From
the moment we walked in, and I know these
are quality problems, the fact that you can
buy a suit that you never intend to wear again
is kind of insane. But I knew that it would
cost close to the same to rent and that we
didn't have time to rent because literally
we found out that we had the opportunity to
go to this amazing show. It's a very small
show with an incredible magician who I'll
mention here because the show is absolutely
spectacular.
And then I'll rewind, so I'm going to get
his name probably pronounced wrong, but Simon
Coronel, C-O-R-O-N-E-L. People, if you don't
know this name, you are going to know this
name. This guy put on one of the best shows
I've ever seen.
Kevin Rose: Young person or?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, he's a young, I mean, I
don't know exactly how old he is. Maybe he's
my age. So I'll call that young. Yeah, just
the older I get, the younger, I think my current
age is. But we went to Hollywood Suits. We
had literally, I want to say 90 minutes. And
we walked in, we didn't even have 90 minutes.
We had an hour. We walked in, we just said,
"Here are our sizes. Where are your suits?"
Went over, grabbed whatever. Looked reasonably
good off the rack.
Kevin Rose: I hate that. Were they itchy?
I hate that —
Tim Ferriss: Well, hold on. So we get, then
it's like, what size is your neck? Shirt?
Boom. The guy throws it on top. Because it's
sort of a rack and stack high volume spot.
Right. And then it's like shoes, belt, this,
that, and the other thing. And we walked out
the door with everything for between $150
and $200 a suit. Okay.
Kevin Rose: That's insane. That's awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So then they can't do the,
we can't do the hemming there. So you have
to go down this alley, around the corner and
you think you might be murdered, but no, you
find somebody who's in this room.
Kevin Rose: You could staple it though. I've
done that before.
Tim Ferriss: You could staple it. We didn't
have staplers though. We have to call an Uber
in 30 minutes to get to this place and we
get everything done. Literally, we walk in
the door and then 45 minutes later we're in
our suits and we go to The Magic Castle.
And my friend and I both have, I don't have
a lot of suits, right? But I have one or two
nice suits for weddings and things like that.
They're not cheap and they're fitted and this,
that and the other thing. And both of us looked
at the suits and they're, okay, these are
not the best suits in the world, but they're
surprisingly fitting and surprisingly good.
And I got a compliment on my suit while I
was there. And it raises questions, right?
When it's like, okay, this was $150-200. So
what differentiates? And yes, they're better
materials. Yes, there's better fitting, but
then you're waiting like five months for alterations
or whatever. When you get into the super fancy
class and you're like, okay, that's not about
entirely quality. That's about the story of
the weight. That's about being able to tell
your friends the process you went through
to get the thing, which is not to diminish
its value.
It's just to say it's really interesting that
so much, such a high percentage of the total
cost could be placed on that. So I think about
these things.
Do you think you're going to get into any
other high-end stuff? Although I want to back
up to your comment that to get the equivalent
in terms of grade for wine —
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — would just be impossibly
cost-prohibitive, right? You're just going
to have to pay out the nose and take out a
second mortgage. So affordable luxuries, in
terms of affordable luxuries, anything else
that you enjoy that you would sort of put
in this same class? For me, one would be chocolate.
You can get, what some would consider the
best chocolate in the world, and if you're
willing to spend even 20 bucks, even 50.
Kevin Rose: What's your go-to? I like Dick
Taylor.
Tim Ferriss: I used to be, all right.
I want to hear yours. I haven't been in this
world for a long time, but about 10 years
ago I really got into it. This is when I was
actually, I guess a little bit earlier, maybe
11-12 years when I was working on The 4-Hour
Chef. Yeah. I got into this and looked at
it very seriously. Coffee, you can really
get incredible coffee if you're willing to
pay up just a little bit.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. The coffee
is one that I do pay up for I, or a subscription,
which is their single origin, high-end coffee
from a roaster called Proud Mary. And they're
based in Australia, but they have a location
in Portland, Oregon as well. And so they have
a varietal of coffee called a Geisha coffee.
Tim Ferriss: Geisha.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Have you ever had it before?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: So it is just like the most delicate,
awesome, floral, beautiful, elegant coffee
you can consume. Whereas when you make it
properly, and I do the whole measuring myself,
32 grams of coffee, 350 milliliters of or
grams of water, and do it via pour over. And
when you do it, you don't need to add anything.
No sugar, no butter.
Tim Ferriss: No butter!
Kevin Rose: I was thinking of the old days
Tim Ferriss: No pork chops!
Kevin Rose: Remember when we did remember
coffee — Bulletproof coffee?
Tim Ferriss: Bulletproof coffee and so on.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Until I started getting my cardiac
markers checked regularly.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God, dude. I used to do
Bulletproof coffees all the time where I'd
add MCT oil and butter and then just, you
basically drink that coffee and about a half
hour later —
Tim Ferriss: Disaster pants.
Kevin Rose: You just shit your brains out.
It's just like the worst. Why did we ever
do that? Then I got my numbers back from Attia
and it's like freaking, yeah, my cholesterol's
all jacked up all over the place.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have an IV bag full of
triglycerides? Like what's happening here?
Kevin Rose: So yeah, I would say you've nailed
it. I think chocolate. Coffee's another one.
Coffee's something, you know, I do a cup every
day. So that's great. Tea's in the same camp,
you can get really nice high-end tees that
are amazing for under $50.
Tim Ferriss: This is going to be maybe funny
coming right after talking about health stuff
and metrics, but I think when I get quite
a bit older, maybe if I'm like, okay, I'm
on the tail end here, I think I might take
up pipe smoking.
Kevin Rose: No! My dad used to smoke a pipe.
Tim Ferriss: I love, just the, it looks so
relaxing.
Kevin Rose: But not inhaling?
Tim Ferriss: And the smell of pipe tobacco.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Is so incredible.
Kevin Rose: Oh, dude.
Tim Ferriss: I think I just want to be a cantankerous
old guy in a rocking chair on a porch, smoking
my pipe, reading my book. I wouldn't inhale.
I guess you're supposed to just bring it into
your mouth and then puff away at it. I don't
know. I don't smoke pipes.
Kevin Rose: I think most people would inhale,
but so I used to go into the old — they
used to have these old tobacco shops you could
go into where they sell raw tobacco. And I
used to go in with my dad, and that's a good
childhood memory. Because the smell is so
amazing. It's incredible. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's really, really, really
phenomenal. So what else would fit that? And
actually people should also just ping us on
Twitter. Let us know if we're missing a category
because I enjoy thinking about affordable
luxuries that most people could bring into
their lives so they can carve out a small
piece of time, a small amount of cash to really
feel like they're treating themselves to something
that is amazing. And there's just certain
categories where that's not possible because
of how much demand there is and therefore
how high the prices can escalate.
Kevin Rose: There's a bunch of stuff. I mean,
for me, there's little tiny micro upgrades
that you do around your household when you
think about this stuff. So I lived near a
convenience store and I had run out of body
soap and I went across the street and I bought
some Dove body soap and it was like cedar
something. I'm like, oh, that sounds okay,
whatever. And I got there. By the time I got
home, I flipped over the back of the label
and it was a bunch of artificial stuff in
there. It wasn't all as pure as the outside
had said. It was on the front. And I put it
on and it was a perfume bomb. It was so nasty.
And I was like, why did I do this? And you
go out and yes, you spend $25-30 more and
you get something from Aesop or a similar
brand and it's just amazing. And you just
speaking of those little luxuries, and I know
that's probably up on the lamer side of luxuries,
but I don't know. I like little things like
that. Little tiny micro upgrades around the
house.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I have a very simple rule
when it comes to soap and shampoo.
Kevin Rose: Well, you're on the dating life
though. You need to have upgraded shit.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, boy. Well, let me pause.
I'll come — we can come back to that if
we want to I know you want to. We'll see.
We'll see where it goes. But I actually get
complimented on my skin a lot. People are
like, what do you use for this and this and
that?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's beautiful. Yeah, no,
it looks great.
Tim Ferriss: It's luscious.
Kevin Rose: It's great. Yeah, it's luscious.
It's very supple.
Tim Ferriss: Supple, moist. Okay. And all
I use, I have for years only used Dr. Bronner's
baby soap. Basically unscented baby soap.
Yeah. I'm getting a thumbs up from your wife.
That stuff is so simple. I never feel like
I have dry skin. I'm bald. So it makes it
easy. Right? It's kind of one tool for all
things. And there you have it. It's not actually
a luxury, but I'm just saying.
Kevin Rose: No, it's great. No, I use that
too, actually. It's great stuff.
Tim Ferriss: And you can buy them in gigantic
sizes. So they last a long time. Yeah. So
that's my comment on personal hygiene and
soap.
Kevin Rose: So, dating life.
Tim Ferriss: No, we don't have to get into
that. Well, what, let's see, we can, well
what are your questions?
Kevin Rose: No, I was just curious how, we
haven't talked about this in great detail,
but I'm curious, how do you change your house?
Talking about the upgrades you have to create
a cozy —
Tim Ferriss: Change my house, well, first
of all, I'm paranoid and crazy about safety
and security stuff. So, generally, I mean,
first meetings are always out somewhere public.
And for anyone who is currently in the fray
of dating apps, they know that it is by and
large just terrible. It's so bad. And yeah,
I've found it interesting. What I would say
is if you're in a relationship and you're
like, wow, this is hard, this is this, this
is that, and it would just be so much easier
if I were single and I'd be having all the
fun in the world and it's like you're just
trading a different set of problems. Just
so, now that's not to complain about it, but
I don't think this subject's going to go anywhere.
We can cut this part.
Kevin Rose: No, we don't have to. I'm just
curious. But have you changed anything in
terms of your workout regimens or anything
like that to get back into fighting shape?
Tim Ferriss: Well, yes. I mean I have been
training. I mean my training's pretty consistent.
I would say that one of the bigger challenges
about dating is that I do not recover, actually
this ties into something. I don't recover
from alcohol nearly as well as I used to.
And the fact of the matter is, generally if
you're going out, people are going to want
to have a drink or it's just going to be social
to have a drink or two.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Nothing crazy. I have no interest
in that. But even two glasses of wine can
completely obliterate my sleep. And so the
jury is out on what I'm going to bring up.
But there is this product which I think you
have tried.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Now I have not tried it. This
was introduced to me by a friend who swears
by it and said he was about to stop drinking,
which might have been a good thing, but he
didn't because he started using this product
called ZBiotics. And ZBiotics is a pre-alcohol
probiotic drink. And there are these, I keep
hiccuping like the Stork from Saturday morning
cartoons after my five sips of beer.
Kevin Rose: Three quarters of beer.
Tim Ferriss: Jesus. All right. So 12 bottles
of this and the basic selling point is that
you are consuming a prebiotic. And I'm going
to bring up the exact prebiotic because I
would love to get some scientific input from
people who can assess this or who have tried
it. Here is the selling point in the pamphlet.
So the world's first genetically engineered
probiotic. I mean “world's first” is always
a strong statement. So I'd be curious to hear
if anybody can verify. But built by PhD microbiologists,
ZBiotics is the only product that actively
breaks down acetal-aldehyde. Nope. I added
an A. I knew I was going to do it, Darya.
Acetaldehyde. I'm just saying it really quickly.
Acetaldehyde, acetaldehyde.
Kevin Rose: I'm going to check one of these
while we're talking.
Tim Ferriss: In any case, it means when you
drink booze, it is intended to help you metabolize
or neutralize at least some of the things
that will cause you to feel terrible. So this
is back to the pamphlet. We started with a
natural probiotic, which humans have been
eating for centuries. Then we altered its
DNA to produce an enzyme that breaks down
the aforementioned word that I shall not repeat.
This enzyme is just like the one your liver
uses, but our prebiotic is designed to deliver
it to your gut, a place where your liver can
access and where you need it most.
So that last paragraph is where I'd love to
have people help me understand if there's
any credible science to back this up. I went
on PubMed. I looked at some of the studies
related to the actual strain of probiotic,
which is bacillus, either soobtillis or subtillis.
So it's either bacillus soobtilus or subtillis,
and that is spelled B-A-C-I-L-L-U-S space,
S-U-B-T-I-L-L-I-S ZB 183. The reason I mentioned
that is when I looked it up, the study seemed
to show that it could mitigate some liver
damage with excessive alcohol consumption
and so on. But I didn't see much on the gut.
Most of the studies seem to be in different
strains of animals and insects like silkworms,
of all things, I think were included. So who
knows how that transfers? So would love to
know what people think.
Kevin Rose: What does your buddy say? Is it
like preventing hangovers?
Tim Ferriss: He said that this has completely
changed his life.
Kevin Rose: But changed in what way? Is he
waking up?
Tim Ferriss: He wakes up without the type
of hangover and costs that have come with
drinking prior.
Kevin Rose: It's like credit cards. Yes, I've
been charged as much.
Tim Ferriss: So other people might bring up
something like activated charcoal. I would
be curious to hear if you found anything helpful.
You have more mileage than I do with drinking
booze.
Kevin Rose: I love this episode. You're like,
"Hey, you like fancy rich shit. Tell me some
about of the stuff us commoners can use. But
first, get started." Dude, you do more rich
shit than I do.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, what? Oh, don't —
Kevin Rose: Oh, you're going to cut that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm going to cut that.
You'd lose that one. All right.
Kevin Rose: So yeah, “you like to drink
a lot. Tell me more. Kevin, you alcoholic.”
Tim Ferriss: You have a broader spectrum of
expertise when it —
Kevin Rose: Oh, thank you.
Tim Ferriss: When it comes to —
Kevin Rose: Oh, well then that you put it
that way.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. When it comes to training.
Yes. In the dark arts of alcohol consumption.
Kevin Rose: So Tim, thank you for mentioning
that. I did get my PhD. I would say that I
did try this at a party about four or five
months ago, and I think you had made a joke
before the show started where — something
about car accidents and a helmet and it's
like if you're going to drive fast enough
—
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no, what I said was there's
a point at which it doesn't really help. Right,
exactly. When you're like, Band-Aids are great
— if you cut your finger, you want Band-Aids,
right? But if you just chop your finger off
—
Kevin Rose: Right? Yeah. So that, that's been
my problem is every time I've tried one of
these, I've chopped my arm off. I was at a
party where it was everyone was passing them
out and I'm like, “The hangover cure. I'm
in.” And then I had five drinks and it was
our big annual NFT party, not this year, but
last year. And it ended up being a lot of
drinks and so I woke up a little hung over.
So anyway, didn't work for me. Crappy product.
No, it could be great. Darya have, you've
tried it. Have you had any success? No, no
success there.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So I'd be curious
to hear what people think. And this is really
broadly to lob a question into the audience,
which is what have you found helpful for hangovers?
And you can just hit us on Twitter with #hangover.
And I'm sure there are going to be a bunch
of sanctimonious people who are like, "I don't
drink, that's what I do." But you guys can
not reply because we don't need those. I've
cut back a lot on booze, but occasionally
there's a place for it. And by the way, all
you folks are like, "I'm enlightened. I don't
drink anymore. I just use ketamine five times
a week." You guys are going to have a rude
awakening in a handful of years.
Kevin Rose: Did you hear that they're finding
fentanyl mixed in with ketamine now?
Tim Ferriss: Of course they are. Yeah. Fentanyl
mixed in with everything. And by the way,
folks, two milligrams overdose, you're dead.
Yeah, if you get stuff mixed in.
Kevin Rose: Don't mess around with it.
Tim Ferriss: Yet another reason not to play
around with miscellaneous powders.
MIDROLL
Yeah. What's up next, Dr. Kevin?
Kevin Rose: I want to talk a little bit about
my obsession with AI.
Tim Ferriss: Yep, let's do it.
Kevin Rose: Because it's changed a lot. So
let me just put it to you this way. Three
to four — you know how I always try new
shit?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: I pride myself in always being
someone to want to play with whatever is kind
of halfway working/breaking if it means that
five years from now I was able to spot something
early on and hopefully identify a trend before
it really took off. So I would say that GPT
when it came out, the ChatGPT, it was one
of those things where the first few versions
were just fun for me. It was kind of like,
oh, I'm having a conversation with AI. Wow,
it's actually producing a real result when
I'm typing to it. It Can help me rephrase
or rewrite a paragraph or it can summarize
some bullet points.
It was doing a lot of little small, meaningless,
more or less tasks, but quite well. And then
4.0 came out. So when 4.0 came out, my consumption
of, in usage of ChatGPT, went from about,
let's call it 30 minutes a week to probably
about five hours a week now.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
Kevin Rose: So I use it a lot.
Tim Ferriss: What are you using it for now?
Kevin Rose: I'm using it to code. So it can
code for me now. So as someone in school that
could always — so my background here, I
studied computer science, but I dropped out
and part of the reason, I don't know how much
I've mentioned this publicly, but part of
the reason I dropped out was that I could
understand code a lot faster than I can write
it. And so still to this day I can read code
just fine.
I mean this, granted, sometimes there's some
syntax I would have to look up or figure out,
but more or less I'm there. The issue was
that if I'm thinking through a problem, it
would take me three to four times as long
as anyone else to figure out the same problem
and I just didn't have the brain for it. Yeah.
GPT, I can come in and as I start to have
little hiccups or I want to think through
a problem, I can just ask it to figure it
out for me and it writes code that is like
99 percent ready to go.
Tim Ferriss: Could you give an example of
a problem?
Kevin Rose: I'll give you an example. Let's
say you're a WordPress user, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Kevin Rose: That's what your blog's powered
on and you're like, hmm, I want to write a
new WordPress plugin and I want it to do this
with my audience. Segment it like this, do
this only when someone is coming from this
country and make it appear like this. And
you know, could change anything you want.
You just describe it in a couple paragraphs
and say go. It literally will print out all
the code for you. You copy and paste it and
save it as a script and you're good to go.
And it works. It's insane.
Tim Ferriss: So what does that mean for say,
five years from now?
Kevin Rose: Well, a couple things. Practically
speaking right now, my engineering team, I
had one of my developers tell me, hey, I had
this, what they would call a kind of laborious
kind of task of just something you don't want
to code. You're like, ah, ah, God, I've got
to resort this data in a certain way and yeah,
this is going to take me 45 minutes. It was
done in five and it's like —
Tim Ferriss: Using ChatGPT.
Kevin Rose: Yes. And so all of those little
meaningless coding tasks, they're just gone.
That's already, it's done. Yeah, it's done.
And so I've been using it to create art and
I can tell it to go and write P5JS scripts
for me, which is what Art Blocks is based
on for all the NFTs —
Tim Ferriss: So art, meaning you're using
code to generate art, objective art.
Kevin Rose: Exactly. And so I can describe
it visually and it comes back with something
that's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool.
Kevin Rose: I'll show you some examples after
the podcast.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'd love to see it.
Kevin Rose: And it's crazy addicting because
you start getting into it and you're like,
oh, what if you take it in this direction,
in this direction? You're limited no longer
by your skill, but your own internal creativity
of your brain.
Tim Ferriss: And your ability to prompt well.
Kevin Rose: Yes, but you can even help it
— so I'll give you an example.
Tim Ferriss: This is about to get super meta.
Kevin Rose: No, yeah, exactly. You can tell
it, "I'm having a hard time writing a prompt.
How might I be more efficient?" And it'll
give you 10 ways to rewrite the prompt and
it just, it's helping itself. It's so nuts.
And so once you realize that it's so much
more than just rewriting a paragraph for you
or helping put together an essay, but it can
actually create real software for you, dude,
I realize now that what's going to happen
is that Marc Andreessen, who's very famous,
very famous, famous venture capitalist maybe
a decade ago of saying, "Software is eating
the world." And so it was this idea that we
had all of these old systems that were largely
pen-and-paper based or weren't connected or
weren't efficient, and software would come
in and be connected, be put the data we put
in the cloud and we would have this new type
of in-cloud infrastructure that would power
everything and be connected like it never
was before.
All of that is still continuing to happen,
but this next generation is what I believe
is AI is going to eat the software. So if
software ate the world, AI is going to eat
the software, meaning that AI is going to
come in and reimagine every single tool that
we use. So every single productivity tool
that we use, it will be a part of almost every
application that we use in really meaningful
ways. I've seen it sort data and create — so
I don't know about you, but when I use Excel,
the hardest thing for me to always wrap my
head around and figure out were pivot tables.
Did you ever get good at pivot tables?
Tim Ferriss: No, I never got good at Excel.
Period.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God. Pivot tables were
one of those things where I was just like,
it was a nightmare to —
Tim Ferriss: I use notebooks and then I lose
my notebooks and I'm screwed.
Kevin Rose: So anyway, you don't have to learn
it any longer. You just tell it what you want,
how you want the data slice and dice and it
just like it not when I would, what I don't
mean is output from ChatGPT, but I mean it
will be working in Excel or in Google Sheets
and just automatically rewrite the tables
for you.
Tim Ferriss: That's wild.
Kevin Rose: You're just going to give it a
little prompt and that's it. And I'm telling
you, this is coming a lot faster than I had
thought. So two years ago it was very linear
to me. I was like, ah, a month after month,
like, oh, yeah, ChatGPT 3 is out now, now
3.5. And I see a little bit of an upgrade
when 4 hit, oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: It seems like everything has
gone vertical.
Kevin Rose: Everything has changed. It's gone
vertical. It's exponential now. And so dude,
the next couple years are going to be insane.
Just insane.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I think the next 12 months
are going to be —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, you're probably right.
Tim Ferriss: Full cuckoo.
Kevin Rose: I'm being conservative.
Tim Ferriss: Full cuckoo bananas. I mean,
I've been, not to the extent that you have
probably, but experimenting here and there,
having my team experiment also to see if people
who are non-technical — I'm non-technical,
but I can figure out quite a few things. People
who really have maybe even an allergy to a
lot of tech tools, like what they can do with
ChatGPT, just to try to peek around that corner.
Kevin Rose: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, what is this going to look
like when there's more mass adoption? And
I ran an art competition, which was an AI
art competition a while back and was absolutely
—
Kevin Rose: This is for the Punch of Cock.
Tim Ferriss: This is for the Punch of Cock.
They Punch the Cock, as they say.
Kevin Rose: You can translate it in so many
languages now.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah. No, it's a massive
global phenomenon.
Kevin Rose: How do you see that in Japanese,
by the way?
Tim Ferriss: Kokkupanchi! Yeah. So yes, that
was for the CØCKPUNCH NFT, which raised two
million bucks, something like that, made 1.7
to two million bucks for the Foundation, which
is great. All that's been deployed, and that's
all fantastic for scientific research. But
the point I was going to make, the art competition
following that where fan art was being generated
using AI, people could also use Photoshop
and other tools to fine tune or to manipulate
anything that came out of, say, Midjourney
or DALL·E or something like that. The results
absolutely blew my mind, and I'm going to
be, you heard it here first folks, so I'm
going to be running some more competitions,
which will have different formats because
a prerequisite or a condition of valid submission
for the competition was you had to capture
your entire process well enough that somebody
could stand a good chance of replicating your
result. And by capturing that, now we have,
let's just say top 10 finalists, you have
10 extremely good tutorials for people who
want to step into the ring and play with it
themselves.
Kevin Rose: So, you've heard of Stable Diffusion,
right?
Tim Ferriss: I have, yeah.
Kevin Rose: Okay, so Stable Diffusion is one,
Midjourney is one, DALL·E, that can create
imagery out of prompts, right? So Stable Diffusion
went open source, which was a big like —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, maverick move.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, yeah. But it was like, oh,
shit, because they release, once you release
an open source —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's gone.
Kevin Rose: Everybody's got it and they're
running with it in different directions, right?
So a buddy of mine gave me a Discord to go
into and he is like, you've got to check this
out. This is crazy. Right? And it's called
Unstable Diffusion.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: And so they basically took all
the guardrails off of Stable Diffusion, all
the protections and shit?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God.
Tim Ferriss: What kind of stuff do you see?
Kevin Rose: Dude? What do you think you see?
Tim Ferriss: I don't know? Deep fake Taylor
Swift porn.
Kevin Rose: I mean, I imagine anything. Anything
you can imagine in its ultra realistic like
state where you're almost like, you look at
it and you're like, is that an image? You
don't even know. It's tricked you already,
but it's the most elegant, it's like it's
—
Tim Ferriss: Just say it.
Kevin Rose: No, it's just, it's porn done
in its finest —
Tim Ferriss: Very tasteful AI porn.
Kevin Rose: No, no, no. But you can do whatever
you want. So there's all these different channels
and so you can go into some channels and see
aliens with six breasts and weird shit like
where you're like, that looks real. Not like
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah.
Kevin Rose: What was it? Not the movie Terminator,
Arnold Schwarzenegger was in with the three-breasted
woman. You know what I'm talking about?
Tim Ferriss: Total Recall.
Kevin Rose: Total Recall, yeah. Not that this
looks a real. It's disturbingly real stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Teenage boys are screwed. They're
not going to —
Kevin Rose: They're screwed.
Tim Ferriss: They're not going to get anything
done in the next —
Kevin Rose: Dude, this is —
Tim Ferriss: — 10 years.
Kevin Rose: No, but they're screwed in terms
of relationships, dude.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I'm telling you, this is what
worries me. So remember the movie Her, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do. So it's a great movie.
Kevin Rose: One of the things about Her, well,
for people that haven't watched it, you've
got to go and watch this because it's going
to be become a reality, is this man that has
a relationship with his phone and the phone
has a very serious AI on it that —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Phone or laptop when he
is at work, right?
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: There's this ubiquitous AI companion.
Kevin Rose: Just following him around. And
one of the things about OpenAI that you can
do now is you can save and train model data
to be persistent.
What you can do is you can go in and you can
say, "Here are the properties of who I want
you to be." And people are doing this. There's
this website that has all these AI hacks,
prompt hacks, they call it. And you can go
in and say, "You are this personality type.
You're a little bitchy, you're sassy," like,
blah, blah, blah. And you can save this and
it will respond to you and learn from you.
And you can have what appears to be a human
conversation with your perfect polar opposite
or whatever you're looking for in life. Dude,
I'm telling you, we're three years out from
that being conversation based.
Tim Ferriss: Have you heard of Replika with
a K?
Kevin Rose: Of course. Okay. I looked at that.
I almost invested in that company years ago.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so you should explain
Replika. They claim to have 10 million registered
users.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. So this was a company that
was raising capital quite a while ago, and
I saw them, but it was before the AI thing
really took off.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: But yeah, I mean this is it. This
is this idea, and I worry because you know,
think of countries —
Tim Ferriss: Replika is Her, just so you guys
know. I mean, there's more to it, but yeah,
that's basically it.
Kevin Rose: But imagine you've seen this,
you would know this better than I would, but
in Japan there's been this decrease in dating.
And I've heard about there's this shame of
whether or not you have a high quality job
enough and there's this disconnect between
the male and female population. Do you know
what I'm talking about? There was a report
that came out on how dating was in the decline.
Tim Ferriss: Well dating and fertility and
—
Kevin Rose: Fertility, yes.
Tim Ferriss: Reproduction in general is on
the decline and they're in a very problematic
situation —
Kevin Rose: So imagine —
Tim Ferriss: — from birth rate replacement
rates, they're in a really sticky, terrible
situation.
Kevin Rose: Okay, so now
Tim Ferriss: I think China could be in 20,
30 years. 20 years probably.
Kevin Rose: But I think we were all going
to be there because I think —
Tim Ferriss: Population implosion —
Kevin Rose: I think you might just have to
have a partner online, an AI, we might just
have AI partners.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I was talking to someone
about this because as you mentioned, right,
I'm single now and they said, "Oh, you should
hop on Replika, just check it out." And I
was like, "I don't actually want…"
Kevin Rose: Did it scare you?
Tim Ferriss: Well, it scared me in the sense
that I was like, okay, there are times when
I'm really lonely and humans are messy. Humans
are difficult. And if you get close to someone,
it's great for a while. You have the honeymoon
phase and things are great and puppy love
and haha, everything you do is so funny. And
then things change and it gets a little more
complex. But if you had an AI companion who,
especially if it were a compelling voice,
oh, which is going to happen immediately,
I mean two years, already I've seen seen AI
— I can't remember the company names, but
that have been trained on voice data to mimic
— and I actually know podcasts that are
being produced right now —
Kevin Rose: This show!
Tim Ferriss: — using AI.
Kevin Rose: We're not even here.
Tim Ferriss: — AI to read scripts that are
sort of pieced together from celebrity sample
data and listeners have no idea. Yeah, they
have no idea.
Kevin Rose: It's so crazy.
Tim Ferriss: These podcasts are not quote,
unquote real because it's not what you think
it is. And we are so close to, they're being
the equivalent of the Scarlett Johansson,
Her, right? Sexy, smoky voice. Yeah. Like
sassy funny. Getting there —
Kevin Rose: Gives you a little shit from time
to time, but doesn't ask you to pick up your
socks.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right. That kind of thing.
Kevin Rose: Darya is looking at me, I'm just,
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
Tim Ferriss: But I didn't want to dig into
Replika because I was thinking there's a chance
you fall from that. It's better than I think
it's going to be.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And then I start playing the
game because I'm like, oh, I'm just testing
the service and then I start getting my human
needs met by this AI and it takes the pressure
off of which maybe sometimes could be a good
thing, but takes the pressure off of human
interaction.
Kevin Rose: Dude, I think this is my point.
This is why I wanted to bring this up. I think
this is going to happen. The question is,
if I —
Tim Ferriss: Children of Men, here we go.
Kevin Rose: Actually, I have a question for
Darya. If I start having an AI talk, I'm talking
to someone on AI that is a female AI person,
is that cheating?
It is?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: What?
Tim Ferriss: That doesn't — no, well, I'm
just repeating what she said. That doesn't
surprise me. I've thought about this a lot
too.
Kevin Rose: It's cheating if I talk to AI?
Tim Ferriss: Well, I mean especially if it's
sexting and this, that, and the other thing.
Kevin Rose: Why is that cheating? It's an
AI. What did she say?
Tim Ferriss: She said, "Well, you don't talk
to me."
Kevin Rose: Well, stop bitching about my socks.
Tim Ferriss: I think that this will become
an absolute issue.
Kevin Rose: Oh, it's going to be a huge issue,
dude.
Tim Ferriss: It's going to be a huge issue.
Kevin Rose: This is one of the things that
it really truly keeps me up being like, I
either need to invest in this company or avoid
it or a combination thereof.
Tim Ferriss: And invest in it so that you
can have your bugout bag and your bunker.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Everything prepared for the apocalypse.
Okay. Speaking of the apocalypse, do you mind
if we switch to —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, let's do it. Let's do it.
That was a fun one though.
Tim Ferriss: Balaji bet. That was a fun one.
I'm glad you brought that up. I'm a spectator
mostly at this point. Maybe I'll just serve
as a stand-in for the audience for those who
are not deeply intimate with crypto or this
world, but what bet, so Balaji Srinivasan,
what bet did he make roughly? We don't have
to get all the dates or anything like that.
And what do you think of it?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so basically for people
that don't know, this is an individual. Balaji
is really well known.
Tim Ferriss: Former CTO of Coinbase.
Kevin Rose: Yes, and also just insanely well-known
for nailing a lot of the COVID predictions.
He came out and said things like really intimate
details, "Masks will be a fashion statement,"
really early on. This is where if you read
this stuff and we all have, historically,
going back, you'd be like, "Bravo." Really
prescient stuff.
So when he talks about the future, a lot of
people pay attention. And so one of the things
that happened with the collapse of a lot of
regional banks with SVB and then First Republic
and others is he said, "This is not an isolated
event. There's going to be a triggering that's
going to lead to hyperinflation, the devaluing
of the dollar. And in the next 90 days, Bitcoin
is going to be worth one million a coin and
I'm willing to stake and bet a million dollars
that is the case," that somebody else had
challenged that.
Tim Ferriss: I think he responded to someone
who said, "I'll put a million dollars on the
line," and he's like, "I'll take that bet."
Kevin Rose: Okay, there again.
Tim Ferriss: I think June 17th or something.
Kevin Rose: Yes, so you're more accurate than
I am. But that was essentially it. So that
led me to pay attention. I was like, okay
—
Tim Ferriss: Well, led a lot of people to
pay attention.
Kevin Rose: Right. Let's dive into this and
figure out what's going on with Bitcoin. And
honestly, what it caused me to do personally
is I hadn't paid attention to Bitcoin in a
long time. I've been in the world of Ethereum
with NFTs and everything else. And there there's
something like nice about how scalable and
green Ethereum is that now that's moved to
proof of stake and there's just a lot more
activity there day to day than there is, say,
Bitcoin.
But I started digging into Bitcoin, and one
of the things I realized is that in a world
where the press cycles are always coming back
to, oftentimes they're hitting Ethereum pretty
hard in that their NFTs go up, they go down,
they go left, they go right. That's like a
bad look for Ethereum, in some cases. People
get hacked, it's a bad look. Like, lose a
certain amount of money —
Tim Ferriss: "People."
Kevin Rose: I know that quite well, but I'm
just saying that there's these certain black
eyes and there's something about the simplicity
of Bitcoin and the store of value that is
still attractive because it's the OG cryptocurrency.
It's still trading at over $30,000 as of the
time of this podcast. And every year that
goes on, it seems to be a more legitimate
asset.
Tim Ferriss: Recording on April 16th.
Kevin Rose: But every year that goes on, it
seems to be a more legitimate asset that is
going to stand the test of time. It's not
going to zero. Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It's a digital currency. It was
the first of its kind. So I started playing
around with some of the layer two that's built
on top of that with the Lightning Network
and noticed that some of the pain points have
been smoothed down a little bit.
Tim Ferriss: Can you explain to people who
don't know what that is?
Kevin Rose: So Bitcoin is notorious for being
just a very low-transaction-per-second blockchain.
So it's, if you threw, say, the Visa scale
at it, how many times a Visa card gets swiped
every day, it would just, it's laughable.
It's like they can do singular, low-double
digit transactions per second, whereas Visa
can do 40,000 plus or whatever it may be.
I'm just, these are rough estimates, but you
get what I'm saying. It's along those orders
of magnitude. So Bitcoin had to figure out
a solution that would scale, help it scale
that infrastructure so that more payments
could happen. And so they created a layer
two that kind of sits on top of it that still
has final resolve or it resolves back to the
main coin. So it has the security and safety
of Bitcoin. It's much how Ethereum is scaling
right now with some of the layer two networks
that sit on top of it.
So their main one is called Lightning. It's
the Lightning Network. And so it allows you
to do ultra fast transactions and it can scale
up to, they say, I think it's up to a million
transactions a second or something. It's something
crazy. They haven't tested it at those limits,
but that's what the paper is written as. Anyway,
so I tried a bunch of this stuff out. I kicked
the tires on a few things and then I realized
that Bitcoin, unlike Ethereum, the nice thing
about it has this finite supply that is slowly,
it's slowly coming to an end over time. So
every, I think it's four, four and a half
years, they do a halving event where they
decrease the total number of issued coins
in half. They do this chop, they chop it right
in half as in terms of the number of coins,
new coins issued, and they're about to do
another cycle here in a little over a year.
So when this next halving event happens, there's
even less currency coming out of that faucet.
So these halving events, I went back and looked
historically and they're typically the year
before the halving event and the year after
the halving event, you typically see a pretty
—
Tim Ferriss: How many halvings have there
been?
Kevin Rose: Quite a few. I mean, so it was
like five now or something like that.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: So you typically see in — don't
get me wrong, I'm not saying — this is not
investment advice, this is not always going
to hold true. But obviously if there's more
demand and less supply, meaning less Bitcoins
being issued, you're going to see a change
in price. Just obviously we know these markets
and how they play out, so no one's talking
about the halving yet. Typically people start
raising chatter around this time and so when
every single other time when a halving events
start to happen and the chatter starts to
spin up, the price has always gone up.
And I've watched this happen time and time
again. So for me, I was like, you know what?
Classic cryptocurrency, I hate that it's not
green. That kills me. I'm happy that more
mining services are going green and they're
moving to cheaper energy sources, which are
typically by thermodynamic and a whole bunch
of the nuclear energy in a bunch —
Tim Ferriss: They try wind.
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: There are a ton in Texas.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so they're trying to move
closer to these energy sources so they can
get cheaper power. That said, I still think
there's obviously a lot of dirty energy that's
being wasted here on Bitcoin mining. It's
a big bummer, but that is the one part that
just gives me a little bit of pause, that
kind of hurts my soul. But I did purchase
a little position there because I do like
it, especially in times where we see the devaluing
of the dollar. We see Russia and China buying
more gold. And I'm just like, "I want a nice
hedge that's decoupled from the dollar, that's
sitting out there." I'm not saying it should
be a big, double-digit percentage of your
overall asset allocation. But for me personally,
I don't mind having a little of that parked
and set on the side.
Tim Ferriss: So maybe you could repeat for
the audience what you said to me. This is
a while back, but when we were talking about
this, and we were talking about what might
happen if the dollar just massively devalued
or if we experience hyper, hyper hyperinflation.
We're carting around dollar bills in wheelbarrows
to buy a Kit Kat at the local 7-Eleven.
Kevin Rose: Well, you and I were talking about
this, and we were like, "Oh, this crazy bet
happened." This was probably, what, maybe
a month ago or something.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And we're like, "This crazy bet
happened. It's a million dollars if Bitcoin
goes to a million." And I was like, "Wait
a second. If Bitcoin goes to a million dollars
and there's hyperinflation, then a million
dollars is worth — " and you said, "Yeah,
the price of a sandwich" or something like
that. And I was like, "Yeah." So it doesn't
really matter. Bitcoin's a hard one because
when you traditionally think about currencies,
you always think of them pegged to somebody
else's GDP. Right? So you think of the pound
being pegged to what's going on in the UK.
It's — what do you peg Bitcoin to?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well, also, there's the
question of like, what is its value in the
absence of a reliable peg?
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: And —
Kevin Rose: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: And if —
Kevin Rose: That's a good question. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: To be clear, I'm sure the maxies
are going to just have a field day with this
one. And there are some people I respect and
admire among that crowd, but there are also
a lot of very aggressive sort of religious
fundamentalists in there, which I'd prefer
not to spend so much time with. There are
a bunch of questions that I have, which I
don't have great answers to, but they're just
questions. One would be what you just described.
Right? It's like, okay, well, if the dollar
experiences this massive hyperinflation, how
does one establish the value of Bitcoin for
the exchange of services or goods?
The second, I think, is for me, what happens
in a place like Europe? What happens in a
place like Japan? What happens in a place
like — fill in the blank — if the US collapses?
So where is the sort of currency safe haven,
if there is one?
And then, the next question is, if things
were to get that bad — and doesn't even
need to be. If we assume, for the moment,
that the rise in Bitcoin price to — let's
just say Balaji's bet of a million — is
predicated on a similar increase in hyperinflation
for the dollar —
Which would just not be sustainable. The whole
country just blows to pieces. Do you not have
more pressing problems than Bitcoin? Are you
going to be able to get on your United flight
to escape the US to fill-in-the-blank location?
You're going to have such a series of questions
that are more fundamental, perhaps, than money
that, if you think that is a likely outcome,
you should be in full-blown, advanced prepper
mode right now.
Kevin Rose: The question, I guess, I think
I have is, are the rails in place for the
preppers to get into Bitcoin? Because if something
happens where we see this massive —
Tim Ferriss: Or the Bitcoiners to get into
prepping properly. But —
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: We can deal with the first.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, so the first one I would
say, it's like if we take a look at — and
this is two of us playing economists on TV,
on the podcast, which is not —
Tim Ferriss: With some booze.
Kevin Rose: — with some booze, which is
never sound advice. But —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. This is not economic advice,
if any central bankers are listening.
Kevin Rose: Right. Yeah, exactly. Please,
come on. Join us. So the one thing that I
think is interesting is, when you think about
what is happening worldwide right now, with
China and with Russia, and we take a look
at the data, what does the data tell us over
the last few months? And what has been reported
is that China and Russia right now are not
buying Bitcoin, but they're buying a lot of
gold. And so that, to me, doesn't signal as
though we have an emergent new world currency
as much as it does instability and a flight
to safety.
And so if there's instability and a flight
to safety, and gold is still the kind of safe
haven for that, which it appears to be, that
would explain why, I mean, since November,
there's been a 40 percent run up on the price
of gold. And so I don't know that Bitcoin
is that safe haven. But there was one chart,
there's one graphic that blew my mind, and
it made me rethink everything. And that is
when the day that SVB came out and said, "We're
potentially insolvent," and all the regional
banks took a hit, there was a screenshot.
Did you see the screenshot? Do you know what
I'm about to talk about?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure.
Kevin Rose: There was a screenshot where someone
saved, to their iPhone, all the regional banks,
all the major banks even as well, and it was
a list of all of them in the Stocks app. Right?
You know how you can list them —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: — and it just goes down the
screen? It's like -20 percent, -15 percent,
-30 percent, just going down the screen.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Kevin Rose: It was just like —
Tim Ferriss: FRB was like -60 or something.
Kevin Rose: Oh, dude, it was just bloody all
the way down. And then there was two at the
top. It was Bitcoin and Ethereum, and they
were both green, heavy green. And that was
the first time where I was like, "Oh, shit."
This is someone's observational data. From
what I can recall, the market has been, more
or less, tightly coupled with Bitcoin and
Ethereum.
Tim Ferriss: Super —
Kevin Rose: The market's down —
Tim Ferriss: It's super tightly coupled.
Kevin Rose: If the market's down, they're
down. Right? It's a speculative asset. And
when people start to feel their pocketbooks
hurting, they pull out of cryptocurrency.
This was the first time where I was like,
"Oh, shit. Some people are moving into cryptocurrency
as the banks start to collapse."
Tim Ferriss: Now, in fairness, that is a subset
of stocks, especially if you're looking at
regional banks and not the S&P 500. Right?
Kevin Rose: Yes. I'm pretty sure the S&P was
down that day too, but I've got to imagine
—
Tim Ferriss: Entirely possible.
Kevin Rose: I've got to imagine whole banking
sector was down.
Tim Ferriss: Let me ask you this. And you
know that I'm pretty heavily vested in these
things. So I'm very deeply interested in Bitcoin.
But just to act as a stand-in and based on,
at least, the homework that I've done, which
your mileage may vary, but the S&P has been
very highly correlated to Bitcoin, and Ethereum,
for that matter.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Right? These are treated as risk-on
assets.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And when things go down, people
sell, especially when —
Kevin Rose: Their most risky shit.
Tim Ferriss: — when you can sell it whenever
you want to sell it —
Kevin Rose: Yes. 24/7.
Tim Ferriss: — and it's not just market
hours, yada, yada, yada. What is different
this time around? Because I do think there
are two issues with the bet. One is that — this
happens to everybody, right — you develop
a — it's not quite a sunk-cost fallacy.
You develop a confirmation bias. You begin
to find reasons to support your book, your
existing positions. And just one more thing.
And that is, I do think the Balaji bet can't
be viewed solely as a prediction, because
people pay attention to him. People purchase
or sell based, also — some people do — Balaji's
predictions and so on.
And it makes me think of this section in Liar's
Poker by Michael Lewis. It's the book that
made Michael Lewis famous. It's a great book.
I think it's mostly about bond trading. And
there was some big, swinging-dick top dog
inside — I think it was Salomon Brothers,
and he bought some position. He was like,
"The market's going up 4x," and he bought
like $500,000 worth. And it started to go
down, and people were laughing, and he had
lost a bet, and people were making fun of
him. And he was like, "Oh, yeah?" And then
he bought like $500 million worth of it. And
the market —
Kevin Rose: Freaked out.
Tim Ferriss: — and went skyrocketing because
they were like, "Oh, my God, somebody knows
something we don't know." So he was able to
move the market. Right?
Kevin Rose: Right.
Tim Ferriss: He made a prediction, but he
also moved the market. I don't think Balaji's
bet —
Kevin Rose: Balaji can't —
Tim Ferriss: It can't move the market. It's
too big. Well, I'm not saying he can't move
the market, but it became global news. Right?
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: You don't think he can move the
market, even if affects larger institutional
players and so on.
Kevin Rose: No —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not saying that Balaji single-handedly
can move the market. I don't think it's fair
to say that it has zero impact on the buying
and selling behaviors of people.
Kevin Rose: Oh, no doubt. I mean, I think
anyone can temporarily move the market. If
Tim Ferriss tweets out, "Oh, my God. One of
my best friends is an insane researcher, just
found a hole in Bitcoin. We're all fucked."
I have a —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Kevin Rose: I have a strong feeling that there
would be some movement in prices. Right?
Tim Ferriss: But you're saying it would recalibrate.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly. Exactly. There's
just too much volume going through it every
single day. Don't get me wrong. It's a hype
cycle, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Cramer's going to talk about it.
It's going to spread.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It's going to have its 48-hour
window, and then there's going to be a bump,
which I think we saw, and then it'll just
recalibrate from there. But —
Tim Ferriss: I thought it was irresponsible
to make that type of public pronouncement.
I would be shocked if it gets to a million
by June, mid-June.
Kevin Rose: I don't know that it's irresponsible.
I just think it's like —
Tim Ferriss: There are —
Kevin Rose: — you're making a bet, and you're
—
Tim Ferriss: There are people who cannot afford
to take their savings and put into Bitcoin,
who are going to do it because of something
like that.
Kevin Rose: Well, the good news is gone up
since he said that. So they're up, regardless.
Tim Ferriss: Well, yeah. It's one thing to
get into a position.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, that's a great point.
Tim Ferriss: As you famously know, because
you're like, "I'm buying this."
Kevin Rose: As you —
Tim Ferriss: And then you never tell me when
you fucking sell things.
Kevin Rose: As you more famously know. We
can talk about your Bitcoin investing.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, Jesus Christ. All right,
man. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Good Lord. Yeah.
Kevin Rose: All right, so let's move on from
there. So I have some fun stuff to talk about.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Kevin Rose: I guarantee you, you're going
to love this next little segment.
Tim Ferriss: All right. I'm excited.
Kevin Rose: Okay?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Kevin Rose: We talked about New Year's resolutions
before.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
Kevin Rose: But I have one that I didn't tell
you about.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: I want to show you something here.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Rose: You're seeing this for the first
time. You can go ahead and read this for the
audience here. What does that say?
Tim Ferriss: It says ABC Letter Tracing Practice
Workbook for Kids.
Kevin Rose: Ages what?
Tim Ferriss: Ages 3+.
Kevin Rose: Okay, and then when you open the
first page, what does it say?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, Kevin Rose, age 45. February
9th, 2023.
Kevin Rose: And then, what do you see from
here?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you're letter tracing.
Kevin Rose: Yes. So I'm learning how to write
with my right hand.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. This is incredible.
It's pretty shaky. Your hands —
Kevin Rose: It is a little shaky.
Tim Ferriss: Your hands are a little shaky.
Kevin Rose: You can see that I'm having some
issues here.
Tim Ferriss: I —
Kevin Rose: Love, stop laughing in the background.
My wife is dying. She —
Tim Ferriss: It's so good. It's funny. It's
funny.
Kevin Rose: She didn't know about this. This
is the first she's hearing it, by the way.
Tim Ferriss: This is great.
Kevin Rose: I have started to learn how to
write with my right hand.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And I decided —
Tim Ferriss: I can see these cute bunnies
and acorns and —
Kevin Rose: It's getting a little better,
right?
Tim Ferriss: — mushrooms and puppies making
it interesting.
Kevin Rose: So, I'm just now getting started.
I've got a ways to go. But this is one of
those things where I was watching my kids
do it, and I'm watching their brains kind
of activate as they're learning how to trace.
And Zelda's really — actually, her letters
were flopped and turned around at one point.
Now they're straight. And —
Tim Ferriss: That's what I do.
Kevin Rose: You did the same thing?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I still do it, dysgraphia.
My letters end up backwards and upside-down
and stuff when I write some letters in handwriting.
Kevin Rose: Sometimes I skip a letter, and
then I come back and rewrite it. I don't know
what the fuck that is, but that's something
I've got. I don't know.
Tim Ferriss: That might be —
Kevin Rose: I get too crazy, and I just jump
—
Tim Ferriss: You have early-onset dementia.
Kevin Rose: Okay, great. Thank you. But the
thing here is, I have no scientific reason
other than to say, I realize that this is
activating, somewhere in my brain, something
new.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And I'm left-handed, so I've always
smudged the shit out of everything I do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Kevin Rose: It's just a streak of ink across
the page because my hand. And I was like,
you know what? My kids are learning. Why don't
I learn at the same time? And so that's something
I started recently.
Tim Ferriss: That's awesome.
Kevin Rose: Anyway, I thought you'd find it
amusing.
Tim Ferriss: Are you enjoying it?
Kevin Rose: Yeah. It's fun. Actually, my hand
gets really fatigued —
Tim Ferriss: It must.
Kevin Rose: — to start. So I set a timer
for 10 minutes, and then I just go to town
and start doing my numbers and my letters,
and then it's like I've got two workbooks
in my office.
Tim Ferriss: That's amazing.
Kevin Rose: I thought you would like that
—
Tim Ferriss: I love that. I love that.
Kevin Rose: Because as a lifelong learner
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Kevin Rose: — this is something that you'd
be into.
Tim Ferriss: I'm totally into it, and I —
Kevin Rose: Do you know what it's doing for
me is helping a certain part of my brain.
Tim Ferriss: Oh.
Kevin Rose: Darya would know.
Tim Ferriss: Darya —
Kevin Rose: She's the neuroscience —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Darya would have more credibility
in discussing this in any capacity. There
is something kind of similar. When did you
start this?
Kevin Rose: Just at the beginning of the year.
Have you tried writing with your left hand?
Tim Ferriss: I have because I've broken so
many things so many times. When I shattered
my right wrist, one of several times, I had
to do all my writing in school with my left
hand. And for the first week, it was terrible.
I was also just thrown into baptism by fire,
which was like, "Okay, now you get to write
for several hours a day with your non-dominant
hand." So I just got crushed.
Kevin Rose: So are you good? Can you —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I don't think I'm good.
Kevin Rose: So you're not ambidextrous.
Tim Ferriss: Especially because left hand
is — I mean, I say it's weird. I'm sure
right-handed is equally weird for you, but
just the whole hook claw.
Kevin Rose: The claw, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So I wanted to pull up the name
of an artist who got me back into penciling.
And she was not aware of this, but she published
a book that I ended up grabbing, which was,
unbeknownst to me, a guide to her tool kit
and approach to much of her artwork. Art walk.
Art walk.
Kevin Rose: Art wook.
Tim Ferriss: Art wook. I'm so tired, folks.
It's not any booze. I slept terribly last
night. Maybe we'll talk about my low back.
I have all sorts of low back issue.
Kevin Rose: I had low back this morning, dude.
Tim Ferriss: So, this woman, I might be pronouncing
her first name incorrectly, but I'm going
to say Eliza Ivanova. And her account on Instagram
is Eleeza, E-L-E-E-Z-A. One of my favorite
artists out there. She's spectacular.
Kevin Rose: Can I see some of her stuff?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. Formerly at Pixar.
And her ability to draw animals and portraits
is —
Kevin Rose: Wow. That is beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: — just spectacular.
Kevin Rose: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: And there's a certain surreal
—
Kevin Rose: Oh, I love this.
Tim Ferriss: — feel to it. See what she's
using here. I'm showing an Instagram video.
She's using a smudging stick instead of, say,
crosshatching, which can be really rough on
the wrists and the hands, to very quickly
create amazing pieces of art. And she has
a number of books. I bought her most recent
book, which gives sort of an overview of her
technique and approach to artwork. And so
I have been — like this type of stuff, for
instance — rather than starting with sort
of a stick figure or a — not quite mannequin
— that's not the word I'm looking — maquette
— Not maquette. But rather than starting
with the bones of someone, starting with the
outline of the figure, then adding shading
—
Kevin Rose: Wow, she's so good.
Tim Ferriss: — then adding the details and
going back and forth. It's so interesting.
Kevin Rose: Don't you just wish you had that
skill set? I mean, you're really good, but
you're not that good.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, she's better. Yeah, she's
obviously much better.
Kevin Rose: Do you have a screen protector
—
Tim Ferriss: But look —
Kevin Rose: — on, by the way?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I do.
Kevin Rose: I can't see at a certain angle.
Tim Ferriss: So this is a new thing. All right.
You want to hear a story? You're going to
love this.
Kevin Rose: You protecting your —
Tim Ferriss: Protecting my screen.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Well, this is a privacy screen.
Tim Ferriss: I went to a restaurant here in
L.A., and sit down at the bar because that's
what's available. Huge bar. It's like 75 feet
wide. And —
Kevin Rose: By yourself?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah, because I just —
Kevin Rose: Was this a date?
Tim Ferriss: No. I'd just finished a workout.
Kevin Rose: Oh, just text me up when you're
doing shit like this. I can come join you
for a drink. That's —
Tim Ferriss: That's horseshit. You're always
super busy.
Kevin Rose: But we're in the same neighborhood.
Tim Ferriss: All right. All right. I'll text
you next time.
Kevin Rose: Please do, seriously.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. So I had done a workout.
I finished, and then I was just like, "Hey,
looking for a place to eat. What can you guys
recommend?" Ended up at this restaurant. Then
I was sitting there. Ordered my food. Having
a great time, beautiful venue, flirting a
little bit with the waitress. That's not going
to go anywhere, but it was fun. She was just
— it was good vibes.
It clearly wasn't going to go anywhere, but
it was just fun. And then, somebody comes
and sits right next to me. There's like 20
empty seats in the bar.
Kevin Rose: Oh, Jesus. I had this one — I
was pissing one time in a movie theater.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, all right. All right.
Kevin Rose: There was 30 urinals, and a dude
walks all the way down and stands right next
to me. And I'm like, "Yeah. Yeah, thanks,
buddy."
Tim Ferriss: All right. So sat right next
to me and, ultimately, ended up being a fan
of mine. And he was very cool. But the fact
that he was sitting right next to me meant
I felt very self-conscious looking at my phone.
I was like, if I look at anything on my phone
or I try to text someone or anything, this
is incredibly visible to everyone around me.
And so I ended up getting a privacy screen
for my iPhone, which is fantastic. I mean,
it's such a simple solution. Also protects
the screen.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it works quite well.
Tim Ferriss: And there you have it. That's
my story about the privacy screen.
Kevin Rose: Cool story, bro.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, cool story, bro. Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Kevin Rose: It works quite well. I'm actually
kind of shocked because I can't see shit from
you, and I'm sitting a foot from you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: I really can't see anything on
your screen.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's —
Kevin Rose: It's amazing.
Tim Ferriss: It's really helpful. Let me try
to find this, and it's going to —
Kevin Rose: All right. I'll start with the
next story while you're —
Tim Ferriss: There is a —
Kevin Rose: — you're trying to find it.
Tim Ferriss: Well, hold on. There's a brand.
It starts with a B. It's not Belcon, Belski.
It's not Belski.
Kevin Rose: Belkin.
Tim Ferriss: Belkin, yeah.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you, Darya. I initially
was looking for a Belkin because those are
well-known, and I ended up being unable to
get it quickly. So I just have something made
in China that is a similar design. So there
you have it, but the key term is "iPhone protector/privacy
screen." And if you search for that, you'll
find something.
Kevin Rose: All right. Now that your privacy
is covered, let's move on to my next story,
which is Nintendo.
Tim Ferriss: Enough about you. Let's talk
about me.
Kevin Rose: So let me ask you a question.
When do you think when Nintendo was founded?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I have maybe some unfair
advantages here. I'm going to say 1880.
Kevin Rose: Yes. How did you know that?
Tim Ferriss: Was I close?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, it's in the late 1800s.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, because 1839 —
Kevin Rose: No, it was like later 1800s. We'll
have to look it up.
Tim Ferriss: 1800s. So the reason I know that
— actually, you probably don't even know
this.
Kevin Rose: No, I don't.
Tim Ferriss: So, there is a Japanese card
game. They're these tiny little cards. They're
like half the size of a business card. And
one of my favorite games I played when I was
an exchange student is called Hanafuda. Hanafuda
has these beautiful drawings. Simply put,
it's a matching game in a sense. And Nintendo
became famous for first making these card
games.
Kevin Rose: Oh, crazy. Can you still buy them,
and they're collectible?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you can still get them.
Kevin Rose: That's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: It's super cool. Super, super
cool.
Kevin Rose: Does it say Nintendo on them?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Oh, it must be in Japanese, though.
Tim Ferriss: It's in Japanese. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Absolutely.
Kevin Rose: Is it little Mario characters?
Tim Ferriss: No Mario characters. But yeah.
Kevin Rose: That would be amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Nintendo. I don't know what the
"nin" is. "Ten" is heaven. And then "do" is
like "place of" so shokudō is a cafeteria,
the food place.
Kevin Rose: I thought "do" was "the way."
Tim Ferriss: It's a homonym. "Do" is the same,
like aikido. Do —
Kevin Rose: — is "the way of."
Tim Ferriss: — is "the way." Different character.
Okay, yeah.
Kevin Rose: Katakana. No, kanji.
Tim Ferriss: Kanji. Different kanji. Yeah,
different character. But "nin" is probably
"sakki nin no ninka na." Yeah. Well, anyway,
we can come back to that. But —
Kevin Rose: All right.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking of Nintendo —
Kevin Rose: So Nintendo. As you know, my first
born is named Zelda.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Kevin Rose: There's a new Legend of Zelda:
Tears of the Kingdom, opening May 12th, which
is soon.
Tim Ferriss: That is soon.
Kevin Rose: I am very excited for this release.
And I started playing the old, original Zelda,
the very first one.
Tim Ferriss: Cool.
Kevin Rose: So you can play it on the Switch.
They have emulators now that you can get on
the Switch. Now, the Switch has the old-school
classic control. Or not the old-school classic.
The traditional Switch controllers. But Nintendo
released the original. These are charging,
so they slide off. Check this out. This is
the original Nintendo controller —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow. That's cool.
Kevin Rose: — that you can get. So —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, that's awesome.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly. So it's —
Tim Ferriss: This brings back so many memories.
Kevin Rose: That's official from Nintendo.
Because you could always find the clone USB
Nintendo controllers that were the fakes and
all that. That has the same feel. You push
the buttons.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay.
Kevin Rose: Everything about it is legit.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, man. That's —
Kevin Rose: And they charge when you slide
them on the side of the Switch.
Tim Ferriss: They charge. That's brilliant.
Kevin Rose: When you link USB. It's so cool.
Tim Ferriss: That's brilliant.
Kevin Rose: Right. Isn't that awesome?
Tim Ferriss: That's super awesome.
Kevin Rose: So they have their pass now, where
you can get all the original Nintendo games.
And —
Tim Ferriss: That's fun.
Kevin Rose: — it's crazy. I was on their
marketplace. And my dad's passed away, and
one of the things that I remember as a child
is there was the original Nintendo Pinball
game. And my dad used to watch me play. He
had, actually had a little tiny TV for me
so I could play next to him as he's watching
his shows or whatever. And I remember he never
wanted to play any games with me. He was an
older dad, and he didn't really get into Nintendo,
but when Pinball came up, he was like, "Okay,
let me grab the controller." And so he played
Nintendo with me. So when I saw that, I was
like, "Oh, my God." I mean, it's so much nostalgia.
Tim Ferriss: What nostalgia. Yeah, exactly.
Kevin Rose: So much nostalgia.
Tim Ferriss: I'll just teach a word for folks
who may be interested in Japanese. They use
it a lot more than we say nostalgia. But they
would say "natsukashii." And that's sort of
got the same feel as "nostalgic," but they
use it kind of like "saudade" in Brazilian
Portuguese. But it's roughly like, "Ah. How
nice." Like, "Aw, that's really nostalgic.
That brings back the memories."
Kevin Rose: There was a blog post that I saw
where it was 25 words that exist in Japanese
that don't have English meanings.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And they're so beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: They have some nice ones.
Kevin Rose: They capture these amazing just
moments in time. There was this one that was
like "The sunlight as it falls between…"
Tim Ferriss: Branches.
Kevin Rose: Branches, yes.
Tim Ferriss: "Komorebi."
Kevin Rose: Yes. Yes.
Tim Ferriss: "Komorebi" is like "Dappled sunlight
coming through tree branches and leaves."
Kevin Rose: It's so good. It's so good.
Tim Ferriss: It's so amazing.
Kevin Rose: They have a word for that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Komorebi.
Kevin Rose: That's so amazing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's super beautiful.
Kevin Rose: Oh. So, I was in Tokyo.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Let's talk about it.
Kevin Rose: Celebrated my 10-year wedding
anniversary out there.
Tim Ferriss: Congratulations again. Yes.
Kevin Rose: That was amazing. And we had a
ton of fun. Darya met me out there. We did
a Moonbirds meetup. So we had over a hundred
Japanese-speaking Moonbirds collectors out
there, which was challenging and awesome at
the same time. And then Henry, my Zen instructor
here —
Tim Ferriss: Shukman.
Kevin Rose: Shukman, here in the United States,
introduced me to the head of his lineage of
Zen, who I got to go out and meet with and
sit down with and have a little private —
Tim Ferriss: Go to karaoke?
Kevin Rose: Yeah, exactly. Went out drinking
and just did karaoke together all night long.
No, but we had a little private gathering
and sit-down and did a private —
Tim Ferriss: Did he lay his hands on you?
Exorcise the demons?
Kevin Rose: He helped me with my practice.
His English is quite good. It was very intimidating.
Very intimidating.
Tim Ferriss: I bet. That's actually —
Kevin Rose: This is the head of the Sanbo
Zen, which is —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, Sanbo.
Kevin Rose: — a big —
Tim Ferriss: Sanbo. That's right. Yeah.
Kevin Rose: — three treasures. A big lineage
of Zen. And I'm sitting here with this guy,
and he's just asking me very pointed questions
about my —
Tim Ferriss: Like what?
Kevin Rose: — intention in Zen.
Tim Ferriss: "What is your intention with
my daughter?" What's —
Kevin Rose: Yeah, more or less. But it was
very cutting questions, dude, like —
Tim Ferriss: Like what?
Kevin Rose: Like a surgeon just coming in
and just — I don't know if I should say
the things because it's this private interview.
I'll give you an example. It's more or less
like, "Why are you here? Where are you?" You
know how in Zen, they have these — we've
talked about these koans before. You've done
interviews with Henry, and thank you for doing
those — where it's like these moments where
a really good Zen practitioner — or not
practitioner, but a good Zen master can come
in and look at a student and know kind of
exactly the little nudge they need to give
them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: There's these moments where they
call it, there's these stories in Zen where
it'll be like they grab your coat and yank
you in a certain direction just to get you
to snap, wake up, this moment, just boom.
They want you to pop.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And it was very much that like,
why are you here? What do you want from this?
Boom, boom, boom.
Tim Ferriss: I think the guy on the street
when I walked back to my Airbnb in Venice
asked me those questions.
Kevin Rose: Exactly, but less fentanyl-driven.
But yeah, so it was amazing. It was very —
Tim Ferriss: HI hear the Zen masters have
cut back on their fentanyl a lot.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. This guy was operating on
a different plane.
Tim Ferriss: So what did that feel like for
you? Why did you want to do it? First of all,
because.
Kevin Rose: Just Henry had said such great
things about him that, and Henry is, he will
never say this publicly, but I believe he
is one —
Tim Ferriss: But I'll say it for him.
Kevin Rose: No, I will. Because I think it's
important. He's such a modest guy that Henry
is one of, I think it's five or so fully sanctions
and masters in this lineage. And that's a
big deal when there's hundreds of teachers
in this realm. So this is his master, his
teacher, and if you get a chance to take that
meeting, you take it. So I went in there like,
"Nah, I'm busy. I'm going to try on some new
shoes." I'm too busy going to try some fancy
Japanese coffee, but which I did, which is
amazing. Cafe Mameya out there is fantastic.
But honestly though, the one thing that I
took away from it for people that I will share
is that one of the things that he asked me
is, he's like, "How often do you practice
and how long do you practice?"
And I said, "I practice 25 minutes a day,
probably five days a week." And he goes, "What
about the other two days?" And I go, "Well,
I've got a startup, I've got this and I've
got that." And he goes, "I don't care." And
I'm paraphrasing here, but he goes, "I don't
care if you've practiced five minutes a day."
He goes, "Don't miss a day, don't break a
day, continue to do it. Don't miss a day."
And since then, I have not missed a day. And
I will say it's kind of amazing because even
if you can sit down for five minutes, it just
keeps that continuity going. And it actually
keeps me at a slightly elevated more, I don't
know. It keeps the commitment stronger, it
feels better. And that was sound advice.
Tim Ferriss: That's great advice. Darya, can
I trouble for just a little bit of water,
please? Thank you so much.
Kevin Rose: Arigatou gozaimasu.
Tim Ferriss: Hai. Arigatou gozaimasu.
Kevin Rose: What? Wait, what's water?
Tim Ferriss: You can do it.
Kevin Rose: Hold on, hold on. Don't tell me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you got it.
Kevin Rose: Oishii! It's so oishii!
Tim Ferriss: What?
Kevin Rose: Oishii.
Tim Ferriss: No, that's tasty.
Kevin Rose: Delicious. Yeah, I know. The water's
tasty.
Kevin Rose: What? Mizu!
Tim Ferriss: Mizu. There are a lot of mizus
out there.
Tim Ferriss: So let's stay on the Japanese
kick for a second.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: This is a book in front of me,
which I'm just digging into.
Kevin Rose: Japanese Death Poems. Let's talk
about Japanese Death Poems.
Tim Ferriss: I did not actually, I'm embarrassed
to admit, know this was a thing. This was
given to me by a friend who has spent a lot
of time in the military and has developed
a rather unique perspective on death from,
I suppose, the vantage point of a lay person,
right? Of a civilian. And so this book is,
I'll just read the quote on the back. This
is one of the blurbs.
"A wonderful introduction to the Japanese
tradition of Jisei. This volume is crowned
with exquisite spontaneous verse and pith
often hilarious descriptions of the eccentric
and committed monastics who wrote the poems."
So these poems are written on the verge of
death. And literally the subtitle is Written
by Zen Monks and Haiku Poets on the Verge
of Death. And it's incredibly well researched.
You have not just the English versions, you
have the introduction and all the context.
You have the Japanese and then you have footnotes
describing what these various words might
mean, what the metaphors allude to. And it's
really just a phenomenal window into an aspect
of Japanese culture that I had no exposure
to. I would've expected that I would've been
exposed to this before, but I'm looking forward
to diving into this. And I've already read
perhaps the first 10 pages.
So this is Japanese Death Poems, by Tuttle
Publishing compiled and with an introduction
by Yoel Hoffmann.
Kevin Rose: So I have a handful, I don't know
if I've told you this, but I have a handful
of haiku books that I've read by a Japanese
masters.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: And one of the things I always
felt was just so beautiful about them is they
always include their kind of death poems at
the very end. So you always get, it's oftentimes
on their deathbed when they're about to pass
what is the last thing that they wrote down.
And it's often in haiku form if they're a
haiku master, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Kevin Rose: And so it's just, it's beautiful
stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there's some really Japanese
stuff in here, right? This is died 19 — I'm
sorry, "Died in 1698": "For not honoring my
parents / while I lived, in my last hour / I
feel remorse." That is very super Japanese.
"The autumn hues / of knotweed seem / like
cups of wine." Yeah.
Kevin Rose: Are you a big fan of haiku?
Tim Ferriss: I am. This is my first time really
being exposed to a lot of Japanese, and it
does sound better in Japanese. There's a certain
cadence to it.
So I'm not going to get the pronunciation
quite perfectly here, but it like if you have,
okay, so Hakuro is this person, died on the
19th day of the 12th month, 1766. So the English,
and I'm going to fuck this up in Japanese,
so I apologize to any Japanese speakers out
there, but the English, just listen to the
sounds, like the cadence. So the English is
"An ailing mallard / falls through the chilly
night / and teeters off." But then the Japanese
is "Yamu kari no / yosamu ni orite / obotsukana,"
right? So it just has a cleaner, crisper cadence
to it, which doesn't mean you shouldn't do
the English, but this is my first time being
exposed to a lot of haiku in Japanese, which
is fun for me. Number one makes very hard
for me to decipher in many cases, but they
have a beautiful sound to them, so.
Kevin Rose: That's awesome. I have to pick
that book up.
Tim Ferriss: Death Poems.
Kevin Rose: There's a great poem about haiku
and about the masters called Three Simple
Lines.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: Have you ever read that?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: It's a fantastic book that is
written by a Zen practitioner that covers
a lot of the Zen masters of haiku and along
with a really beautiful personal story. Very
short read. Definitely worth picking up along
with this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I mean, how Japanese relate
to death, which is something I have some exposure
to, but not to the poems. This particular
Jisei format tells you a lot about how they
live. I mean, it does provide sort of a prism
through which you can appreciate how they
navigate a lot of life as well in addressing
the final hours and thinking about dying,
death, the path to death.
When you get a better understanding of that,
many of the things that you observe in Japanese
culture make more sense, in a way.
Have you ever done an escape room?
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: You have?
Tim Ferriss: How many?
Kevin Rose: Multiple.
Tim Ferriss: Really?
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Multiple. What does that mean?
Like a hundred?
Kevin Rose: Like four.
Tim Ferriss: Four. All right. So by the —
Kevin Rose: They're so stupid.
Tim Ferriss: The fatigued way. So I, all right.
"They're so stupid," he says.
Kevin Rose: They're horrible.
Tim Ferriss: I did my first escape room today.
I had a fucking blast. I don't know what's
wrong with you. You're getting old and boring.
Kevin Rose: No, it's just like you're going
in there and it's like, what are you doing?
You can get out if you want to. Are they really
locking you up? No.
Tim Ferriss: It's called a game, Kevin.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I know. But —
Tim Ferriss: When you're playing Zelda, you're
trying to do shit in a video game. You don't
actually need to do those things.
Kevin Rose: No, but I just, Darya can explain
it. You know what I'm talking about. You go
in there and they lock you up. It's a little
room and they're like, we really quick grab
the book and open up the book and turn to
chapter 12, and people are yelling shit out.
And you're just like, I don't want to do this.
I just want to have a drink.
Tim Ferriss: All right. So I'm going to provide
a contrast in styles here. So Kevin, who got
so outraged that I implied that he drank alcohol
earlier —
Kevin Rose: No, I just, all my friends want
me to do it sober. And I'm like, why are we
doing this sober? And they're like, you can
get through it faster. We could break a world
record. I'm like, this is dumb.
Tim Ferriss: Look, doing it in a hyper-competitive
way I think is probably not my jam. But I
had the chance to do escape rooms for the
first time today. I went to this place called
Escape Revolution, which is here in L.A.,
Elan Lee, who is one of the co-founders of
Exploding Kittens, was kind enough to invite
me. I don't want to name other people who
were there because maybe they don't want to
be named. But it was a small group and I thought
it was absolutely fantastic. You have an hour,
there's some type of pretext or story, there's
a narrative arc. So in our first instance,
and I'm not going to give away any of the
tools, so I won't provide any teasers, but
we had a real armored car that's locked in
a garage.
Kevin Rose: That's cooler than mine.
Tim Ferriss: And you have to, you're robbers
and you need to get the money out of the car.
But the mechanic who set up all the security
systems ran off because the police were on
the way. So you have 60 minutes to figure
it out.
And we had a blast. And this place is built
in such a way that the set design and the
sound effects and the entire experience makes
it, I don't want to say cinematic, but it's
just a very compelling way to become immersed
in a story. And you have to collaborate, I
also, part of what made it fun is that I have
a game designer in Elan Lee. I had a number
of other people who were very accustomed to
mechanics of different types. Not car mechanics,
but game mechanics and so on. A woman who
had done almost 2,000 escape rooms herself.
Kevin Rose: Jesus.
Tim Ferriss: Which is all to say it was a
cool group of people to interact with.
Kevin Rose: They were into it.
Tim Ferriss: Well, they were into it, but
then there were two newbies. I was one of
those two newbies who'd never done this before.
And then the second one was a jail break,
and we were locked in cells, which were legitimate
cells with —
Kevin Rose: Was that solo?
Tim Ferriss: What are you talking about?
Kevin Rose: Did you have to figure out how
to get out of your own cell?
Tim Ferriss: It was three people to a cell,
and then you needed to figure it out.
Kevin Rose: I kind of wish it was solo. I
don't know. I just have this hard thing where
it's like we're all yelling shit. And I'm
just like, can we just relax for a second?
Tim Ferriss: I don't know what your group
was like. There's no yelling. There's no yelling
in this group. Yeah, no, this group.
Kevin Rose: Do you like it? Yeah. Darya doesn't
like it either.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Kevin Rose: She hates games.
Kevin Rose: It's one of those things where
maybe I haven't had the right experience because
the ones in Portland were kind of jank. I
don't remember much. I just remember that
we went in there and there was just shit hidden
in little bookcases and stuff. And I'm just
like, why am I looking through these bookcases?
There's other things to do. I've got emails
that I haven't checked. There's a lot of shit
going on.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, my God.
Kevin Rose: But it felt like work. It felt
like work. It felt like work where I'm like,
why am I working to figure out this thing
when it's not even a thing?
Tim Ferriss: Well, I mean, you don't need
to work out in the gym to outrun hyenas on
the street. So what are you doing in the gym?
Kevin Rose: Well, I mean that you can actually
get a physical good feeling for the gym. Suns
out, guns out, that kind of thing. Well, I'm
glad you had a good time.
Tim Ferriss: I had a fucking great time.
And one other thing I did this weekend, which
I'd never experienced, and if people have
the chance I would recommend, is experiencing
high-fidelity immersive sound for the first
time, actually listening to music in a store
or a location where they're paying attention
to all the variables. The most I have ever
done is really to the extent that I personally
can set up a few Sonos speakers in a house.
That's as fancy as I have ever gotten. And
I was having dinner with a few friends, well
one close friend and a few new friends who
are professional musicians, and they heard
me say this and they were like, "Whoa, whoa,
whoa. Okay, we need to go to a good location
and put you in a seat to let you listen to
some of the music you think you know."
Kevin Rose: Where did they take you?
Tim Ferriss: In super high-fidelity, this
place called Common Wave.
And the staff there were exceptional. We went
from one setup to another setup to another
setup, to another setup. And it was spectacular.
I mean, it was having a full-blown psychedelic
experience in some respects.
So for those who may have the opportunity,
if you have the opportunity, I really came
to appreciate just how much goes into music.
I thought I knew, but it only listened to,
in hindsight, relatively low bit rates. And
it is just a different experience altogether
because this came about initially at dinner
because I asked somebody at dinner who, who's
a TV writer, I asked him if he ever watches
TV and has trouble immersing himself in TV.
And he said, "I don't really watch TV." And
I was like, "Well, what do you spend your
time doing if you're just having fun?" He
said, "I listen to music."
And I was like, "You listen to music while
you're doing something else, or you listen
to music as a dedicated activity?" And he
said, "I listen to music as a dedicated activity."
I was like, "Okay, tell me more about that."
And that's how we ended up.
Kevin Rose: So one thing you might want to
consider, I've been down this path a couple
of times, and there's two ways to approach
it. One, you either go high-fidelity system
for your house or you go really high-end headphones.
And I recently realized that back even just
two years ago, to do a high-end headphones
setup required its own dedicated amp.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Kevin Rose: It was like there's a whole rig
that you have to get. More recently now, lossless,
over-the-air audio codecs that can go to headphones
that sound amazing.
Tim Ferriss: So over-the-air, you're saying
Bluetooth?
Kevin Rose: Yeah. So I got a Bowers and Wilkins,
I think it's the PX7. It's something along
those lines. And these are sub $1,000, but
they're still pricey. I mean, I think they're
like $800 or something like that. And they
can do a lossless codec from your software
or from your iPhone to your headphones. And
so there's no bit degradation in quality.
And Apple Music now supports lossless as well.
And so you can listen to insanely high-fidelity
audio and just sit back and relax and enjoy
the music in the headphones. I mean, you'll
see the reviews out there, but they're fantastic.
Tim Ferriss: Huh? Okay. Well yeah, that would
be substantially less expensive.
Kevin Rose: Oh, my God, dude, I've seen some
setups and I'm sure you have too. Or you talk
to these people. I mean, you're a couple hundred
thousand dollars in.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, easily. Yeah. If you really
want to get up to the nerdiest of the nerdy
and the most expensive of the expensive, and
I do think there's a dramatic drop off.
Kevin Rose: We talk about wine, all that there.
Tim Ferriss: There's a point of diminishing
returns, but there are people out there who
spend $100,000 on a cable.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, I mean it's crazy.
Tim Ferriss: You can get as expensive as you
want to get, but you can also, I would say
the in-home systems are certainly going to
be more expensive than the headset you're
describing.
Kevin Rose: It's funny, we met with someone
recently that was an audio/video person. So
Darya and I are, we're in an apartment now
and we're moving into a home at some point
here in the future. And there's this person
that was like, "Hey, I can come do your home
audio/video stuff." And I literally told the
person, I was like, "I just want Sonos. I
just want Sonos and a decent pair of speakers."
Because for me, I don't want to spend insane
amounts of money when I could just put on
an amazing pair of headphones and kick back
anywhere in the house and either read a book
or just relax and listen to — I'm not going
to spend several hundred thousand dollars
when you can probably spend 10 grand and have
an amazing setup. Right? Yeah. It's going
to sound great. Movies, all that stuff's going
to sound fantastic. I don't know, for me,
audio's not one of those things that I want
to blow money on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Well I've got my relationship
with my Replika and a nice, single life ahead
of me so I can just sit in the house by myself
in a dark corner listening to Pink Floyd,
crying, and eating Ho-hos.
Kevin Rose: As your Replika whispers to you.
I've got to try this Replika now. Is it that
good now?
Tim Ferriss: I haven't dared set foot.
Kevin Rose: You haven't even dabbled —
Tim Ferriss: No.
Kevin Rose: Like, "Hey, Replika."
Tim Ferriss: No, no, I haven't. I have not.
Although a few friends have.
Kevin Rose: Really, they like it? Do they
get into sexual encounters with a Replika?
Tim Ferriss: I haven't heard that yet.
Kevin Rose: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think it's there.
Tim Ferriss: It will get there. I'm sure it'll
get there.
Kevin Rose: If they're not going to build
it, they're silly, because somebody's going
to build that in very short order.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I'm just
imagining Neuralink type. I don't think virtual
sex, which will ultimately debilitate all
males on the planet, once that is actually
a real thing. But nothing will get done ever
by any man ever again. But the, there's been
a lot of attention paid to haptic suits and
that type of feedback with, say, VR.
Kevin Rose: Adam Gazzaley loves this.
Tim Ferriss: Haptic suits and they just all,
they're all —
Kevin Rose: We always bring up Adam in every
podcast.
Tim Ferriss: That's right. We talked about
his chin hair last time. The haptic suits
I always have found interesting, but kind
of dissatisfying because it doesn't replicate
your human experience. It feels like something
vibrating on your chest by and large.
Kevin Rose: Yeah. Like I'm wearing a suit.
Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I'm wearing a suit that's —
Kevin Rose: Right. Darya's doing chest in
air quotes.
Tim Ferriss: Well, so okay, let's take it.
Let's say I had a haptic glove on my schlong.
Right? It's still not going to feel like the
real McCoy. It's just not going to be.
Kevin Rose: Have you tried all the crazy things
they have out now? Because they have those
ones that look, they have different types
of materials that's supposed to feel more
realistic.
Tim Ferriss: I have not. What are we talking
about?
Kevin Rose: Well, they have those —
Tim Ferriss: In concrete terms. In concrete
terms.
Kevin Rose: Okay. I've heard that they have
those skin ones that there's locked down and
they're supposed to feel, really —
Tim Ferriss: You should work in a Foley studio.
That was great.
Kevin Rose: But they're supposed to lock down
and feel really realistic. You don't act like
you've never heard of that shit. You know
more about this stuff than I do.
Tim Ferriss: I don't. I would look, let me
just be clear. I would try that. I have nothing
against it. I would try it. I just think at
some point I'm going to be, I feel like I'm
like boning a Mattel toy or something. Right,
right. So where I was going with the Neuralink
is, I think rather than the haptic suit, there's
probably going to be quite a bit. Well, at
some point I could envision just having a
direct link in where you can simulate, I mean,
I guess generate really the type of sensation
that you would have.
Kevin Rose: Well, I think this is going to
be the opposite. So here's what I think is
going to happen. I think we're going to have
VR, or sorry, not VR, but we're going to have
essentially AI that comes in and we'll have
a relationship with, and then earpieces will
go into real humans that will play the role.
Tim Ferriss: Like Her. That's exactly what
happened in Her. Remember?
Kevin Rose: Oh, is that what happened at the
end? I don't remember.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. So they arranged
to have a normal person come in, this woman
comes in.
Kevin Rose: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: She's got an earpiece and he's
got an earpiece and the idea is they don't
communicate. He's just communicating with
Scarlett Johansson, who's his AI.
Kevin Rose: I've got to watch this movie.
It's been a decade since I've seen it.
Tim Ferriss: And then they have sex and he
has a camera. I think they had cameras so
that the AI could also see what was going
on and comment on that.
Kevin Rose: Oh, yeah. Darya's saying The Diamond
Age book by Neal Stephenson. It's supposed
to be —
Darya Rose: The VR is basically played out
by actual actors. And that's a job.
Tim Ferriss: I've heard great things about
The Diamond Age. I have never read it, but
Neal Stephenson, author of Snow Crash, some
people will recognize.
Kevin Rose: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: My favorite book actually, Cryptonomicon.
And a lot of people hate on Cryptonomicon,
but I just absolutely loved it. So go for
it.
Kevin Rose: I've got to go back and listen
to Snow Crash. All right. I think I'm done
with my stuff. You covered everything.
Tim Ferriss: I feel like we're stopping on
the Mattel toys. That's fine.
Kevin Rose: Exactly. We've covered, oh, I
have a gift for you.
Tim Ferriss: You have a gift for me?
Kevin Rose: So here's my last story. My last
story is that when I was in Tokyo, I realized
that LEGO is obviously pretty popular phenomenon
amongst a bunch of my Silicon Valley friends
actually, it's like a time that you can get
off the computer and build LEGOs. They have
something called Nanoblock.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Kevin Rose: Out in Japan, which are really
tiny. I don't know how they got around the
patent of LEGOs. They're really tiny little
baby LEGOs. And I got you this little castle.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wow.
Kevin Rose: Himeji Castle.
Tim Ferriss: Look at that.
Kevin Rose: Yeah, this is a little tiny castle
and —
Tim Ferriss: Thank you.
Kevin Rose: These are small. They do very
traditional Japanese structures in —
Tim Ferriss: They even say "The original micro-sized
building block."
Kevin Rose: All right. So anyway, if people
want to eBay it or check it out, it's actually
really cool because just recently LEGOs started
adding things like bonsai trees and stuff
like that. When I was walking down the aisles
in Tokyo of this store, these Nanoblocks,
they had all these traditional, beautiful
Japanese structures. And so if you're looking
for something, if you're into LEGO or know
somebody that's into this whole thing, and
I have a lot of friends that have built Back
to the Future cars and every other LEGO that's
out there, check out Nanoblock because they
have a bunch of stuff that has very obviously
Japanese influence that you might be really
into.
Tim Ferriss: "Small blocks, big fun." I'm
just reading the side here. Chiisana tanoshimi.
"Nanoblock is a micro-sized building block
designed in Japan since 2008. Fun to build,
attractive to display, interesting to collect."
Kevin Rose: Something tells me that LEGO was
around before 2008.
Tim Ferriss: It was definitely around before
2008.
Kevin Rose: Like the original — 2008. Anyway,
dude, this'll be something to get off the
computer and just like do. It's tiny, so it's
a little fun little thing. I got a couple
for friends.
Tim Ferriss: "Oh, my AI girlfriend, I built
you a Himeji castle with Nanoblock." "Thank
you, Tim. That's my favorite. You know how
to please me." All right. On that note.
Kevin Rose: With that.
Tim Ferriss: God save us all. Yes. All right.
Kevin Rose: Thank you, everyone.
Tim Ferriss: Thanks, everybody.